[Musique]
j'adore dessiner tout simplement des
chats je suis assez prolifique dans ce
domaine et là le fait de célébrer en
Saint-Paul ça me parlait
moi je viens souvent à Saint-Paul mais
connaissance de des lieux j'arrive à
situer quelques endroits mais oui ça me
donnerait envie de visiter un peu plus
en tout cas la commune et ses environs
ma spécialité c'est vraiment la nature
et là on m'a demandé de faire l'étang
saint Paul et le pont
j'ai pris en compte mon personnage
fétiche à savoir little Momo l'idée
c'était qu'on ait un regard de dos et
qui est celui qui regarde c'est un peu
une mise en abyme la personne elle
regarde tout en regardant une personne
de dos et en gardant le pont et toute la
végétation source en fait
[Musique]
et j'essaie de combiner mais vraiment
avoir un mon personnage il est central
certes et mais c'était plutôt la nature
je voulais mettre en avant et puis la
beauté de ce lieu
[Musique]
j'adore travailler avec d'autres
personnes c'est vraiment mettre en avant
des cils et des univers complément
différents ça nourrit en fait aussi mon
imaginaire donc ça c'est c'est assez
chouette en soi
il y a une bonne ambiance donc c'est en
plein centre ville donc venez quoi voilà
[Musique]